soon here in downtown Las Vegas we're
about to see a new Performing Arts
Center open its doors we're talking
about the Beverly theater filling a void
for independent arts in the valley
Candace Charles is live this morning
inside the Beverly with the plans for
Premiere week in March Candace good
morning to you
good morning John good morning folks
okay I'm in the place where it all
matters right the theater now these
seats are nice but that's really not a
big plus about this theater it has so
many capabilities you guys can watch a
movie in here you can come maybe have a
party in here if you'd like if a lot of
things you can do in here it's pretty
awesome I'm joined by creative director
Kip Kelly thank you so much for joining
us tell us about the capabilities in
here oh man this thing is unique I think
there is a lot of things in here you
would not see in your average film house
we have a very busy ceiling grid we've
got theatrical lighting everywhere these
seats retract into the wall so that
gives us a lot more floor space and GA
space for concerts we have an acoustical
wall that opens and closes so we can
open up to the Courtyard we have
microphones in the ceiling that allow us
to control the Acoustics and the reverbs
of the room so uh performers and artists
in here can pretty much tell us what
they want the room to sound like and
we're able to make that happen q and A's
discussions concerts films this place is
set for all of it I love it I love it
you guys can have poetry reading of
course we talked a little bit about some
of the film festivals the big ones so
it's not like it's going to be a lot of
things going on really quickly tell me a
little bit about Debbie week uh debut
week we've got uh really cool films
going on we've got a concert going on
we've got some literary Pro programming
going on uh a few of those uh community
events are for everybody and they're for
zero dollar RSVPs and they'll be more uh
information on that very soon but we're
really excited to kick things off March
3rd it's going to be a good time
awesome Kip thank you so much for
joining us as he mentioned March 3rd is
the big day March 3 the 7th will be
debut week we got all the details on our
website eightnewsnow.com coming up we're
showing you guys the outside of this
place because that place is also
beautiful but for now live from The
Beverly theater I'm Candace Charles 8
news now all right Candace thank you
this you look nice I hope the stage
looks nice looks pretty cool in there
all right